hey david do you think that donald
trump's new tone around coronavirus
taking it more seriously and wearing or
carrying around the mask is going to
help him turn the election around
i i don't think so no i mean i think
it's too little too late you know
for the first four or five months of
coronavirus in the united states
trump continued to say everything's fine
refuse to wear a mask
masks are you know it's your choice you
can wear it or not wear it or whatever
we have 15 cases it'll soon go to zero
etc etc etc in the last 10 to 14 days
we saw trump with a mask out in public
he keeps it in his suit pocket
during his coronavirus press briefings
to be able to pull it out like a prop
at any time he has actually said some
things that are more sober like it could
get worse before it gets
better and on and on and on will this
turn around the election for donald
trump
i don't believe so um i don't believe so
because
number one the cat is sort of out of the
bag from the standpoint of coronavirus
even if indeed the trump administration
is now covering up
cases since the changeover from
reporting data to the cdc
instead reporting data to health and
human services we covered that earlier
this week
people know that they're unemployed
people know that their friends are
unemployed people know the economy is a
catastrophe people
disapprove of trump's handling of racial
issues which is the third most important
issue going into november so i think
trump putting a mask on now
and saying this is tough is simply not
going to be
enough now could it still be important
as far as keeping people safe in other
words will trump supporters start
wearing masks because trump has worn a
mask
i seriously hope so because that is one
of the most important things that we can
do we covered on a bonus show earlier
this week
there's a lot of hygiene theater you
know restaurants announcing we're going
to close an hour early
to spray with some disinfectant the
entire
restaurant or whatever there's really no
evidence that significant contagion is
happening through surfaces
in that way you know cleaning tables and
seeding surfaces between guests
uh should be more than enough so there's
like hygiene theater stuff that does not
really seem to hold down contagion
wearing a mask does wearing a mask when
you're indoors
avoiding crowds that's the stuff that
really matters and so
if trump carrying his mask around helps
more trump supporters feel okay
putting on a mask then that's great and
i would be crazy to oppose that and i
don't oppose it
now there's one other component to this
it is possible that trump wearing a mask
and then more people wearing masks as a
result will
increase the number of people that feel
comfortable going and voting in person
in november maybe there were people in
november who maybe were going to stay
home
but now we're going to go out now i'm
thinking of democrats
what i mean is the following if you're a
trump supporter
and you're already not paying attention
to masks you're going to go out and vote
in person in november
if you're a democrat and you care about
masks and they aren't mandatory or a lot
of people aren't wearing them
you might stay home because others don't
plan to wear a mask
you seeing more republicans wearing
masks
might make you as a democrat more
comfortable going out to vote in
november
and that would be great it would be
great if trump wearing a mask
increases everybody's mass compliance
which makes more democrats feel
comfortable
going out and safely voting in november
if the death toll goes down
significantly that may actually be what
helps trump
the most and the mask wearing could be
part of it but it's a long path
right the mask wearing you need eight to
ten weeks to flatten the case curve
it's about another 15-20 days to deal
with the deaths
and then we're at election day so i just
don't know that the timing is going to
work out
unemployment going down stock market
continuing to climb i don't think is
going to do very much for donald trump
in terms of the polls
it really fundamentally comes down to
can donald trump avoid another major
mistake like
the response to the george floyd protest
was a disaster trump's now more than 20
points underwater on racial relations
compared to joe biden disaster trump's
early coronavirus response disaster you
know carrying the mask around now i
think is too little too late
the resulting economic damage and the
fact that
1200 bucks is what's gone out to some
people disaster
if trump can avoid another major mistake
if deaths do start to go down
if the economy does start to improve in
a real measurable way that will help
donald trump but ultimately he's
desperate he knows it
and it is now about lying about the
numbers to try to hide them
and and trying to suppress the vote
which is why we have to work really
really hard
to prevent that from happening we have
to overwhelm the vote by so much
that the voter suppression trump will
plan to do is planning to do
won't be enough to hand him a
re-election victory one of our sponsors
is privacy.com they're giving you
five dollars when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin
air it'll even autofill the card number
with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy
the virtual card number right after
using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with a free plan you'll protect
your financial info companies can't
charge you unexpectedly and like i said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman